let's bring in fox news headlines 24 7
sports and entertainment reporter mike
gunzelman mike great to see you on the
program look putting aside the fact that
he could break the grand slam record
that's obviously very notable to sports
fans to me isn't the outcry less to do
with djokovic and more to do with the
draconian australian covid policies in
the first place
yeah i mean this is just a a wild
situation altogether todd because i i
actually put the blame on a lot of
people here djokovic probably should
have known the law a little bit better
or at least entrusted uh better people
before he was going to fly into
australia now of course he thought that
he followed all the proper procedures
and uh and did have this medical
exemption but you got to know the laws
before you go somewhere for example you
know if if women are going to go to a
certain middle eastern countries you
want to know exactly what you're getting
yourself into if an american wants to go
to north korea you don't go to north
korea in general so you have to know
what you're getting into before you go
to a foreign country especially during
these times but you're exactly right
because this goes beyond just djokovic
it goes to the fact that the australian
country in itself right now these
policies are insane and this is not a
good look for the country of australia
but i i understand where the outrage is
coming from
from the people okay they haven't been
able to see family members from other
countries a lot of them in certain parts
of australia can't go to restaurants
can't go to bars they are in a lockdown
so when they see somebody come in just
because he is the greatest tennis player
right now
they're frustrated they're frustrated
and mad at djokovic and they're
definitely angry at their own government
right now for these insane mandates that
are happening okay but mike before we go
to the next topic i just just want to
point out uh djokovic is worth what 220
million if you were to win the this 21st
i mean he'd get a little more than two
why not just say hey take a stand at
these policies be like i'm not going to
compete
well if he i i completely agree with you
to that to an extent maybe he just
doesn't want all the attention that he's
getting essentially right now he's being
he's a political pawn and he's being
used as an example and because the prime
minister has an upcoming election
he has a ton of pressure on him as well
because if he gives him an exemption
well the people are gonna be very angry
because they're gonna be like why'd you
give it to djokovic to nobody else now
will he change his stance perhaps
djokovic that is and be like hey i'm
being used an example right now i am
gonna stand up against this
authoritarian type government sure but
but he's not he's not a citizen of
australia so he either has to embrace
this full on or
as we see right now he's just stuck
inside a detention facility and he's
worth over 200 million dollars it's it's
just a crazy thing all around and it
just shows how insane these policies are
and it's dividing the people against
each other there's a lot of hatred and
animosity right now between the
vaccinated and unvaccinated and
especially these governmental policies
hands down no doubt about it we got to
go quick on this yeah we got to go quick
on this final topic the nfl drawing up
super bowl contingency plans in case
covid forces a move from la
potentially they're looking at dallas uh
keep in mind events like the grammys and
sundance or any postponed are going
virtual look the nfl makes contingency
plans for every single super bowl but
mike what are the chances that this time
they could have to use them
well i i think this actually it could
very well happen because as you just
mentioned the grammys have already been
postponed we're seeing a lot more
hysteria on postponing events concerts
getting pushed back and everything
it's all about timing but timing is a
double-edged sword right now they do
have five weeks until the super bowl but
because it is the super bowl they have
to figure out what they're going to do
sooner than later on top of everything
else california is obviously an absolute
mess it's a liberal hello right now and
they have 1800 plus health care workers
from out of state
in their own hospitals right now because
they're so understaffed are you really
gonna bring in all the festivities
surrounding the super bowl which is more
than just the game
i don't know so as of right now if the
cases do not go down i do not believe
that the super bowl is going to be held
in los angeles and get ready dallas
yeah and mike and then they're talking
to texas obviously where it's free and
open so okay mike gunsman thanks so much
a lot going on in the sports world hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now